lewinsky monica lewinsky a name so 1998
I think I hear the Armageddon soundtrack
playing in the salon where I'm getting
my Rachel but the woman behind the
biggest or at least most recent or at
least that we know of presidential sex
scandal in history is back with a cause
cyberbullying because she claims she was
the first person to have their
reputation completely destroyed
worldwide via the internet it's true we
all lost something to AOL chatrooms
didn't we but nowadays it's even easier
to get bullied online Lewinsky says the
public shaming she endured made her
contemplate suicide like 18 year old
Tyler Clementi the boy who inspired her
newfound quest in 2010 the Rutgers
student killed himself after his
roommate streamed a video of him kissing
another boy whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa you say i was watching power
rangers in 98 monica did who with the
what and how let's take a moment to
recap in turn gate in 1995 President
Clinton started a relationship with then
White House intern Monica Lewinsky even
though at the time he was already caught
up in a sexual harassment lawsuit
brought against him by paula jones who
said he'd shown her his private bits at
a hotel room years before when he was
governor of Arkansas but that didn't
stop Clinton from hooking up with Monica
in a windowless hallway by the Oval
Office during a government shutdown I
mean who didn't get it on during the 95
furlough I am i right there was a cigar
a blue dress stuff you can read about
him way too much detail in Kenneth stars
report a 480 page brick that star wrote
after he got evidence of the affair from
Monica's frenemy Linda Tripp who gave
him tape she'd secretly recorded in
which monica totally copped to it which
might not have been so bad if bill
didn't then testifying the Jones case
that he'd never had quote sexual
relations with Monica leading to his
impeachment but he still got to stay in
office Monica went on to rep for Jenny
Craig start a handbag line and star in a
British TV series Monica's postcard
turns out it's not easy to have a career
when there's only one kind of job your
name is associated with but back to
cyberbullying what I want to do now is
help other victims of the shame games
survive to
serious she even joined Twitter winski
got more than 70,000 followers in just a
few days proving that there's at least
one real way to succeed on Twitter
change your name to Monica Lewinsky but
I am mad at you mom if Bill Clinton
didn't go anywhere why should you one
more download the agent plus mobile app
and join the conversation available in
your app store now